virus coverage now let's take a look at  the latest numbers nevada reports a 16.3  percent positivity rate while clark  county's slightly higher at 16.7 percent  meanwhile clark county is reporting 230  cases per every 100 000 over the last  two weeks now that number needs to be  below 100 for restrictions to start  easing our our goal here at eight news  now is to help you get all the latest  information in one place so we created  this qr code you see there on your  screen just point your cell phone camera  at it and a link will pop up click on  that and it'll take you to our eight  newsnow dot com website where we explain  all this information all the covet  numbers you can also find a full list of  vaccination and testing sites around the  valley